let's go to our caller from the eight
five seven area code who's calling from
eight five seven hi this is that hey Sam
actually caught up on me I'm caught up
in Cleveland um so my question to you is
about BDS suppose that I wanted to ask
call in as before long time
I had a day off work today and I just
finally got a chance I know you don't
support it and I kind of understand why
but to recreate it seemed that the
reasons you don't support it are kind of
right-wing wheat reasons or what I would
consider right-wing reasons and I think
to me that you're mostly afraid to be in
kind of a political bedfellows with
people you don't you disagree with so
that what would be all the let's let's
let's break it down piece by piece
what's an example of a right wing reason
why you perceive I don't support the BDS
movement okay so I know a lot of you who
don't support BDS for instance they
don't support it because they they say
that there are people within the
movement or all those who support the
movement who are people who I would also
disagree with even as somebody who does
support it people who want to get rid of
Israel who have a legitimate agent of
use and I think it seem like a lot of
people who are afraid of supporting it
ask me to be afraid of being political
bedfellows with those type of people
oh no I'm not afraid of that I don't you
said this is something that other people
do so I don't know if are we talking
about what you perceive my reasons to be
or other people that you know no no this
is one of the this is from my
understanding of when I ever hear people
talk against BDS it seems to me one of
the many reasons that I hear people say
if it is this one and the one and
there's one other reason and it's I
think this other reason come from a
confusion of how video started I
actually saw a post from a Facebook post
imagine it was recently where he kind of
joked about why aren't people doing
boycotts of all these other countries
that have human rights violations mm-hmm
and it seems to me that he has a
fundamental misunderstanding of how BDS
started es started for my understanding
because the palace peaceful Palestinian
wanted a non-violent peaceful way of
protesting what they perceive as
oppression you're saying pal
Gillian's who are you're saying
Palestinians who are in other countries
right or are you saying Palestinians who
are in the West Bank in Gaza
I mean in West Bank and Gaza and around
the world they they wanted the world to
support them in a peaceful nonviolent
way of resisting so they call for BDS I
mean we all disagree with Hamas as more
militaristic tactics okay of course but
it seems to me that if you disagree with
Hamas as violent resistance you disagree
with the peaceful Palestinians move for
a peaceful resistance
what are we leaving the people can you
okay there's a few confusions here even
every every detail of it but so what you
have to understand is that in the West
Bank
tons of Palestinians are working for
Israeli companies and are traveling into
sort of Israel proper for lack of a
better term and they're they're not
boycotting Israeli companies that's
that's the number that's the first thing
you have to understand so the idea that
this is what Palestinians are calling
for and want isn't true now one of the
reasons I'm not hold on one of the
reasons I oppose BDS is that I believe
in the long term it's actually going to
hurt a lot of Palestinians if it were to
be successful now it's been years now
and I don't see any evidence that it's
actually going to be successful but if
people want to keep doing it by all
means do it I'm gonna lobby for change
in other ways and I don't think it's a
right wing I don't know if it's a common
right wing thing to say I care about and
I'm concerned about Palestinians and
that's a priority and figuring out what
it is that I support that doesn't sound
right wing to me and so in what way are
you are you voicing your opposition and
you have a meaningful way I'm calling
listen I don't live in Israel so it's
like how am i I have I have no more say
about whether Netanyahu stays or goes
then I have about whether Shinzo Abe a
stays or goes but I'm an opponent of the
Netanyahu government I believe the
Netanyahu government has to go I don't
think they're arbiters for
i lobby for an end to all settlements
which I believe to be illegal and an
impediment to peace I mean you know
there's a whole long list of things I
lobby for okay okay thank you all right
thank you appreciate the call